what are the top five things a filmmaker
should look for in a distributor
the first one i would say for any
business deal
but it's really really hard to gauge is
honesty
like how do you gauge honesty how do you
gauge that in a partner had to engage
that in a friend
you know in a in anybody so
it would be great if there was a honesty
test
but honesty is the most important thing
like
trust slash honesty you just want to do
business with people who you can trust
and who you think will be honest with
you so sometimes you would gauge it
through
reputation you might ask other
filmmakers you know
how they did you know like you can say
the distributor who else did you
distribute for
can you give me some references some
other filmmakers of course they'll give
you the ones that went well not the ones
that
were mad at them but you could ask you
can go on a website
you know their website see all the
different films maybe
look up some of the producers of those
other films and you know and email them
or phone and contact them and say hey
did you get a fair deal how did it go
and get it that's how you would gauge
that
but then again that's perspective from
somebody else but at least it gives you
a
sort of a good test um
their business acumen like
do they seem professional does their
website look professional
is do their is their office organized
are they
you know professional getting back to
you on time and communicating with you
um you can sort of tell if if
people are acting professionally or not
and if they're not professional chances
are they're
maybe not professional with their
clients and they're going to be a pain
to deal with
so hopefully they don't have to be the
biggest and most
the nicest office they don't have to
have expensive offices in beverly hills
they just it's got to be seem to be
organized and they
you have to get the impression that they
know what they're doing you know and
that they treat you with some respect
hopefully even if you're not the biggest
client you know it's
how hard is it to return you know an
email or something like that
what is their breadth their reach into
the marketplace
have they been at it for a while do they
have the customer base that they
actually say
can they get to streamers can they get
to broadcasters
can they get to international
territories do they really can they
really do
what they claim they're gonna do and so
that's also maybe a question you asked
some other filmmakers
or you know maybe you could look them up
you goo
it's amazing when you google people you
know and companies what you can find out
um i happen it's easier for me because i
go to the markets
so like i see if they're there i see if
they have booths there i see what their
stands look like i s you know i see them
in cocktail parties and meetings you
know
it's it's much easier when you're in the
business to know if they're in the
business
and sort of what their breadth is and
you can also talk to
other people like other producers in
other countries and something like that
and say do you
or other distributors do you know them
have they done business what do you
think da da da so you can also try to
gauge that as much as possible
um their
their track record on reporting
reporting is a big thing
because even if they're doing the
business and they're not telling you
about it
you know it's aggravating i'd say that's
one of the major complaints that just
that indie film producers have with
distributors is they don't report
you never know what's going on and uh
when they do report it's
usually fabricated you know
so that's the honesty thing we talked
about before
so you want to see that what the reports
look like that they
you know you want to sort of get some
type of indication that they're going to
be
regular and honest with you and then the
last one would be
i guess their distribution deal what
kind of deal they're offering
you know does it feel like it's a fair
deal do they feel like they're trying to
hold you do you feel like you can even
make any money with it
um again they're in business to do the
best deal that they can for themselves
but
did they does it feel like you know you
have a shot with them
and hopefully you need to get some
advice to make sure that you make the
right deal with them because it's not
their responsibility
for you to make the right deal i mean
some people take it upon themselves to
make sure that the deal is totally fair
i mean i have this adage that i always
said i'm really big on fairness fairness
is a huge
theme for me in my life i always say a
good deal
and i learned this on the distribution
side not on the production side
a fair deal not a good deal a good deal
is whatever works for you
a fair deal is one where you sit on this
side of the table
and you negotiate and you you have to
call everybody compromises but
you get to something that you're
comfortable with and then you switch
places and
on that side of the table you're equally
comfortable and both people feel
equally compromised but equally
comfortable that's a fair deal
it's unfair when somebody gets it all
and somebody is left with nothing
and it doesn't have to be equal they
just you just have to feel that it's
fair
how can a filmmaker negotiate a fair
deal with a distributor
well in order to negotiate a fair deal
you got to know what to ask for
i mean if you don't ask for the right
things you're probably not going to get
them
like fair is fair right it's i keep
saying it's not the
distributor's obligation to make sure
you get the fair deal it's your
obligation
so you have to either surround yourself
with people who know what they're doing
or
figure it out yourself know what you're
doing that's any negotiation
you got to know what to ask for or
you're not going to get it
don't assume somebody's going to put it
on the table unless you ask for it
so you know you got to do some homework
or you got to hire somebody to do it for
you
then don't get mad if you got a bad deal
because maybe you didn't ask for the
right things no you're allowed to get
mad
everybody gets mad i mean that's part of
being human
um but be mad at yourself
that's who you should need to be mad at
mad at yourself you know it's hard to
get mad at yourself when you
you didn't even know you know how
like it's not like you knew and you left
it out you forgot
you didn't even know so you're mad i
guess at the circumstances
but it's your obligation as a it's your
obligation to your movie
saying your movie's like your child and
you want to protect it it's your
obligation to protect your movie and
make sure that you either
let somebody who knows what they're
doing do it for you or
or know what you're doing figure it out
and don't
be don't don't leave yourself short
so no one's going to come in and say you
know well listen we're not being fair on
our end
really what we should most most
filmmakers get this
even if the filmmaker on the other end
of the table didn't ask for that
if you didn't ask for it kind of like
off
is fair and more in love then it's not
going to happen for you you have to
really know what it is
that you are actually defending against
or trying to get
and they're not going to suggest it for
you listen most distribution agreements
should start off
relatively reasonable
relatively but
they're not always it's your obligation
to make sure that you get it to the
total reasonable and fair place sure i
mean i would think after years and years
and years of doing it that
distributors would hopefully not take
too much advantage but
they do and and it's it's not their
fault
you gotta like it you spend all this
time effort and money
making your movie spend a little bit of
money
getting it represented properly and
distributed properly
it's just as important in some ways it's
more important
you